Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Imaginez, vous avez tout mis en œuvre
pour réaliser votre rêve.
Vous êtes prêt.
Tout semble aller comme sur des rails.
Et soudain,
la porte se referme.
Un grand vide s'installe.
Vous ne savez plus si ce que vous êtes
en train de vivre est réel ou non.
Le doute s'installe.
Et pourtant,
vous n’avez rien fait de faux.
Alors, comment se relever
d’un rêve brisé ?
Peut-être que certains d’entre vous
ont déjà vécu une telle expérience.
Pour ma part,
faisons un petit retour
en arrière dans le temps.
Nous sommes le 25 avril 2015, il est midi.
Avec mon mari, nous avons obtenu
ce fameux permis tant convoité
pour une expédition à l’Everest
depuis le Tibet.
Nous devions donc entrer
sur territoire chinois.
Cela signifie également qu’une fois le
visa délivré par les autorités chinoises,
seule la date mentionnée
dans le visa fait foi.
Aucune autre.
Pour nous, il s'agissait du 25 avril 2015.
Une date que je n'oublierai jamais.
Ce jour-là, cela faisait plusieurs heures
que nous étions en route depuis
Katmandou, la capitale du Népal.
Quand soudain, à quelques kilomètres
de la frontière avec le Tibet,
la porte du rêve de l’Everest
se referme brusquement.
Sans prévenir.
Comme dans un film.
Nous sommes projetés
dans des scènes surréalistes.
Les images défilent à toute vitesse,
sans comprendre.
Une femme debout devant sa maison
complètement détruite,
elle est en pleurs.
Des gens qui accourent de toutes parts.
Des enfants pieds nus
qui se prennent par la main.
Et tout ce monde, y compris nous,
se dirige vers le seul endroit
qui nous paraît être le plus sûr
dans cette vallée terrifiante.
Et voilà que la terre se remet
à trembler de plus belle.
Des blocs de rochers se détachent
de la montagne.
Les gens sont terrorisés.
Les dieux grondent.
Nous apprendrons plus tard
que nous nous trouvions en réalité au
cœur d’un terrible tremblement de terre,
à deux kilomètres seulement de l’épicentre
de 7,8 sur l’échelle de Richter.
Nous sommes [coupés] du monde.
Quatre jours, comme dans
une trappe, sans issue.
Des blessés qui affluent de toutes parts.
Une femme qui accouche
au milieu de la nuit,
dehors,
dans le froid humide
du mois d’avril.
Les conditions d'hygiène
sont désastreuses.
Jusqu’à ce deuxième jour,
où un couple assis au milieu
des décombres de sa maison
nous offre des bols de riz.
Le riz, ils le cuisent
sur le feu de bois alimenté
par les poutres de leur maison détruite.
Quatre jours.
Quatre jours et enfin,
nous apercevons les hélicoptères
qui pourront venir rapatrier
les blessés à Katmandou.
Puis, c'est le tour des touristes.
Lorsque les portes de l’hélicoptère
se referment
et que nous survolons un pays
comme en guerre,
cette image de ce couple assis
dans les décombres de sa cuisine
ne me quitte plus.
Peu avant de décoller,
ils avaient répondu à mon mari
qui voulait leur donner de l’argent
pour reconstruire quelque peu
leur maison entièrement détruite
en échange des bols de riz
qu’il nous avait offerts.
Ils lui répondirent
avec un sourire sur le visage :
« Seule la valeur
des bols de riz compte. »
À ce moment,
le rêve de l’Everest est loin,
très loin, comme enfui.
Et c’est en silence que
nous atterrissons à Katmandou.
Mais avec une seule idée en tête : venir
en aide à ce peuple qui avait tout perdu.
Oui, mais comment ?
Par où commencer ?
Nous n’avions jamais été au cœur
d’une telle catastrophe humanitaire.
Non.
Mais nous avions miraculeusement survécu
à ce terrible tremblement de terre.
Donc dans nos esprits,
il n’y a plus qu’un mot : action.
Et là, comme par magie,
tout s’enchaîne très vite.
Du premier sac de riz que
nous avions encore à la maison
aux 31 tonnes de vivres
que nous sommes allés distribuer dans
les vallées les plus reculées du Népal,
45 jours se sont écoulés.
45 jours
où nous avons fonctionné
comme des automates.
45 jours jusqu'à l'expiration de mon visa,
mais surtout 45 jours
où nous avons fait confiance à la vie
et honoré cette confiance
qui avait été placée en notre petite
association à but humanitaire
que nous venions de créer quelques mois
auparavant, The Butterfly Help Project,
avec comme but de venir en aide
aux familles des sherpas
décédés lors d’expéditions.
Une année auparavant,
mon mari avait perdu
son meilleur ami lors d’une expédition
et il avait dû se battre
pour que la veuve puisse subvenir
aux besoins de la famille
et surtout que les enfants puissent
continuer leur scolarité.
Alors,
lorsque vous avez un rêve
et que vous avez vécu une telle expérience
qui sera à tout jamais gravée en vous,
croyez-moi,
l’énergie pour le réaliser est décuplée.
C’est donc tout naturellement
que douze mois plus tard,
on se retrouve au pied de la montagne.
Mais cette fois-ci,
avec tant d’émotion,
tant de souvenirs dans nos cœurs.
Et c’est ainsi que, pas à pas,
nous avançons dans la nuit,
le souffle court.
Le froid qui nous transperce.
« Il est là, le sommet, tu l’as vu ?
- Oui, il est tout proche.
Il semble tellement proche.
- Oui et non, mais en réalité,
il est encore tellement loin.
Allez, dix pas !
Dix pas de plus. »
Et un arrêt s’impose.
Autour de nous,
le silence,
ce silence profond de la montagne.
En réalité, nous évoluons
à plus de 8 500 mètres d’altitude
dans cette fameuse zone de la mort.
Et là, les questions fusent.
« Est-ce que je suis suffisamment prête
pour réaliser enfin ce rêve,
pour atteindre
cet objectif tant convoité ? »
« Est-ce que la météo tiendra ? »
« Un plus un, combien ça fait ? »
Avec mon mari, nous décidons
de faire confiance à notre météorologue,
tout en sachant que la moindre des erreurs
à ces altitudes peut être fatale.
Mais nous sommes une cordée.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de mots
pour nous comprendre.
La montagne,
elle est notre alliée.
Et l’expérience de mon mari
sur les plus hauts sommets du monde,
un précieux atout.
En principe,
lorsque vous rêvez d’une telle expédition,
vous avez déjà lu les récits les plus
tragiques de l’histoire de l’Himalaya.
Alors, quand votre mari,
à 8 848 mètres d’altitude,
à 3h45 du matin, vous dit :
« Les conditions météo sont parfaites,
donc on reste pour le lever du soleil. »
Eh bien, mon cerveau avait beau
être en déficit d’oxygène,
il était encore suffisamment lucide
pour réaliser que nous allions affronter
le moment le plus froid de la journée,
et ce sur le plus haut sommet du monde.
Pour mon mari, c’était la neuvième
fois qu’il gravissait l’Everest.
Moi, la première.
Donc je n’avais aucune idée comment mon
organisme allait réagir à ces altitudes.
Non.
Mais à ce moment,
nous sommes cette cordée avec cette
précieuse confiance l’un envers l’autre.
Un moment magique, un instant
comme suspendu dans le temps.
Les étoiles scintillent de mille feux.
La pleine lune nous éclaire
de sa douce lueur.
Nous sommes seuls, mon mari et moi,
sur le plus haut sommet du monde,
l’Everest.
Alors,
ce que je souhaite vous dire ce soir,
c’est que pour moi, la cordée en montagne
est la plus belle preuve de confiance.
Et quand vous avez la chance
de pouvoir admirer un lever
du soleil à 8 848 mètres d’altitude,
sur le toit du monde,
en compagnie de l’être aimé,
les mots ne suffisent pas pour
exprimer tant d’émotions partagées.
Nous avons dû surmonter tant d'obstacles.
Oui.
Mais nous avons fait confiance à la vie.
Nous nous sommes fait confiance.
Les obstacles, ils sont faits
pour être surmontés.
Vous aussi, faites confiance à la vie
et surtout, faites-vous confiance.
Merci pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)